what's up everyone welcome back to the
supper suite for another Tiff 2022
interview for one of my favorite films
of the festival Nanny congratulations
congratulations and thank you I adore
your movie so so much nikkiato I feel
bad doing this because you've probably
done this a lot from Sundance to here
but can you give us a brief synopsis of
nanny for anyone out there who does not
know what your movie is yet okay the
brief synopsis is a West African nanny
in New York City who's from Senegal is
preparing for the arrival of her son
that she left behind in her native
country as she prepares you know to chip
away at the American dream she's haunted
by a force that threatens to dismantle
everything that she's built it's a good
tease without spoiling anything so I was
reading a little bit about how it was
like a seven to eight year writing
process and at one point you stopped
writing why did you stop writing and
then what came to you in order to keep
it going and evolving it in a way that
you wanted to film The Script eventually
you know what I stopped writing for my
sanity because uh you know sometimes
with financing is such a soul-sapping
process of figuring out which feature is
going to get the money first and so I
always say that this wasn't my first
feature idea this was the first one that
got money to be made and so you know you
throw a few things at the wall and you
hope something sticks and this was the
one that stuck so now looking back is
there anything about Nanny being the
first to go that is making you think I'm
so glad that was number one because it's
going to influence my future films in a
positive way amazing question
um it's the little it's the big little
film that could so it's it's super
ambitious and my other ideas are even
more ambitious so in retrospect I
understand why they didn't go first so
I'm glad that I was able to have this
learning curve especially with DFX like
this is a whole separate realm from
straightforward drama I feel like I am
in this chair in this industry for the
big little films that could so those
fill my heart so so much
um Anna for you I'm I'm also Mighty
obsessed with the movie us and I know
you're working with monkey paw in the
future so is there anything about your
experience working with that company and
Jordan on that film even though it was a
I'm about to say smaller role there are
no small roles but you have less screen
time in that movie than you do here is
there anything about that experience
that you found influencing how you
tackle the genre movie in this case in a
lead role
um
I mean to be honest I just found it
really curious that Horus seems
attracted to me to be honest um Jordan
offered me that role and I took it
obviously because it's Jordan peel and
um and I love his work and and I love
the the world he creates
um but yeah I I
just I do I find it curious that this is
a genre that
um seems to seems to find itself back to
me it's the fourth uh horror film I've
done Manny and and so it's just curious
but um
what influence I don't know I I I don't
know that it necessarily
just working with black directors that
are
um expanding the genre in a way that's
never been done
um was a parallel that you know I was
really excited to get into
so this script comes your way is there
anything about the character that you
kind of like circled in read and said
that experience or that quality of hers
is going to be the most challenging for
me to bring to screen and then
ultimately did that turn out to be the
most challenging thing or did something
Catch You by surprise on set
yeah I mean
it's a character that I felt so deeply
um close to and understood
um and
what surprised me
I don't know honestly just working
alongside these brilliant actors really
was the most surprising thing
um because they just key you in in a way
that's really gorgeous
um but I don't know no when you have
good leadership and a Clear Vision
there's no surprises because you have
everything you have everything planned
out and everything went perfectly right
of course as it always does
um Michelle I'll apologize in advance
this is like a big convoluted
three-parter but okay I was watching
another interview you did where you said
after you read the script you had to sit
with it for a little bit so what was
your big takeaway immediately after that
first read what came to you after you
sat with it and then once you started
working on it was there any other layer
that emerged that you appreciated that
you didn't realize was there before well
I I had to sit with it because honestly
I was really taken aback I had never
read anything like this before I don't
think there's anything out there that
has this perspective this voice you know
you have a very very unique voice we're
telling a story about an undocumented
immigrant and we're seeing
the the film through her eyes through
her perspective and I had never read
anything that kind of had my brain
spinning in terms of creatively in terms
of what John
it was it was like an internal drama but
then it was an external drama and then
it and then it became very confronting
for me as a white woman and that is when
I went okay I'm I'm uncomfortable here I
need to dig deeper on this I have
Goosebumps actually just recalling that
moment and
when I watched then nikiatu's suicide by
sunlight her wonderful short film I went
holy [ __ ] I I have to do this I have to
meet her and we met on zoom and we were
really taken with each other I just knew
this was a filmmaker I was going to be
so excited to collaborate that I was
going to learn so much from not just
creatively but personally and we did
nikyatu created such a beautiful space
for us to develop the characters in such
a free and vulnerable way and the the
film is filled with a lot of subtext as
you well know and I think that's why
it's going to get under a lot of
people's skin but to be able to do that
in such a comfortable and vulnerable way
as we did in our rehearsal process was
really really special I'll I'll build on
that and ask a question to the whole
cast here so Nick yatu's first feature
here you're already going on to make
another one I'm sure there will be many
more after that what is something about
her as an actor's director that you're
really excited for even more actors out
there to get to experience in the future
he's so giving
she wiped the snot out of my nose
in the middle of a take because she
didn't want me to have to leave or blow
or do anything and she knew I was in a
space
and I don't know I you know I I adore
her I love her I admire her I'm in awe
of her she's giving she cares about her
actors
um
yeah she made space for rehearsal she
made space for us on the days to to
speak about and explore and she would
encourage us to ad-lib if
um we felt necessary and she has no ego
about what it takes to make the most
authentic thing yeah so
yeah I think you nailed it she's got
very you've got very little ego like
you're very collaborative and very open
to any ideas you guys this is you also
have an insane vocabulary which I think
which I think actually is a really
unique and great characteristic when it
comes to a director because sometimes
all you got to do is come in and say one
word and that can just change the whole
dynamic and I just feel like that you
really inhabit a lot of those
communicative
skills that are so important to deal
with all the various different processes
that actors sort of bring to the table
as well like I think the biggest thing
like you guys one word but attentive
throughout the process and I remember
the days when I was on set and it was
all of us it was me it was on it was
Nick yatu and we're going through
different
spectrums of the story
she was always so attentive nikyatu was
always so attentive to everything even
what you were feeling are you okay
you're in a good mood like what are you
feeling and it was always something that
I just noticed there's a difference to
me between a director and a filmmaker
and I think a filmmaker is always very
inclusive to that to not just their
process but the atmosphere their crew
the environment and they care and you
always get to feel that in the story and
you know typically a director will
always have the structure
but she's a filmmaker in there she's
very attentive in that process that was
what I noticed the most I love this so
much I know I wasn't expecting we
haven't seen each other in so long
and we haven't been together to
celebrate this film this is officially
the first Festival where we're doing
this yeah wait officially officially
because Sundance is virtual I actually
feel like that was probably a really
good path to go on because I feel like
Sundance virtual gave a lot of people
out there who might not have access to a
film festival the opportunity to see
your phone but now you're still getting
to experience it with a live crowd and
doing these interviews together so Best
of Both Worlds right here Cinco I wanted
to go back to you for your character I
don't want to spoil anything okay but
can you tease anything about his
relationship with his grandmother that
is informing how like he carries himself
and how he's dealing with this situation
because I can watch a whole companion
film just about his past with his
grandma I mean you know that was
something that that was really special
to me and nikkiato and I talked about
that that's a lot of art imitating life
if anyone who knows me personally and
probably has listened to me speak knows
how close I am with my grandmother I
speak to my grandmother every other day
when I'm going through really major life
choices and looking for Life advice
cycle I literally called her this week
to ask a decision about something that
was going on in my life
so I think that connectivity of someone
who is so maternal for her for not for
her but for him was the one thing and I
think she guides the character in the
movie The Character Malik through the
movie
through understanding his process and
understanding the elements of the
universe that exists Beyond his own
understanding which gives him an ability
to understand certain aspects of what
honest characters going through as well
you know
um but I think that was her her pivotal
position and just being that matriarch
that just guides him along the journey
you feel it I love it yeah um another
element of this film I love is the
folklore at what point in the writing
process do you decide that a Nancy and
mommywata are the right elements to
enhance the story and I guess like what
came first the general idea of how this
situation progresses for her or maybe
coming up with them and then filling in
the gaps based on what that folklore
contains really good questions so I
first and foremost was the story of
Aisha this domestic worker my mom on and
off for a few years I'm Sierra Leone
people are conflating me and honest both
being Senegalese which I don't mind I
like Senegalese culture but you know my
I'm first gen American and my mom did
some domestic work so that was the
launching point for this and then Anansi
and Mommy Wata are two very prevalent
and and two of the most visible herbal
black diasporic figures of resistance
throughout history for black people from
many different countries and also
indigenous people like everybody has a
trickster figure in their folklore and
Anansi is just one of many and
um but also cinematically they're both
just really
fun to bring to life in a live action
form and Anansi is a Chaos Agent and I
think chaos agents are always fun to
watch I love what you're able to say by
incorporating folklore but this is also
why I love horror in general I just feel
like you're able to convey a lot more
about human truths than through like a
more standard grounded drama and that is
why I'm so drawn to the genre in general
feel like I could ask you so much more I
have to let you go soon but I wanted to
ask you about your next film because
I've already brought up uh monkey paw I
don't know what you're allowed to tease
about the story but if anything can you
share anything about the story but okay
so a safer question then what is
something about monkey paw and Jordan
peel as a company as and as an
individual that you think is going to
allow you to add an extra like tool to
your tool kit or a layer to your next
film without them we're going to be
spoiled after this yeah the bar is high
so uh I just have so much reverence for
Jordan peel as a as a filmmaker
um I don't use the word auteur often
because it's such a collaborative
process like is autoship real but he is
Paving away for filmmakers like me who
are interested in navigating social
issues through genre
um and he's really smart about it and he
has so much reverence
for Cinema like he's constantly planting
these Easter eggs in his work that pay
homage to filmmakers before him and so
in in all of those ways I just really
respect him and his process and his team
and feel like it's it's a very organic
place to land for my next project so I
obsess over his films as well likely be
why I obsess over your films I cannot
congratulate you enough on this movie
Nanny is fantastic to everybody out
there keep an eye out for Nanny trust me
thank you so much for watching this
interview we will see you with more Tiff
2022 interviews very very soon